[Applause]
[Music]
happy
november hope you had a grand halloween
i'm sure kat and emily did
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh not surprising
so for halloween weekend what did the
virginia democrats and the lincoln
project come as
racist
which was easy because that's what they
are in real life it's like if joy behar
went as the loch ness monster
not a stretch
yes they did this in a state where it's
democrat governor either a war blackface
or a kkk hood for fun
that's a whole lot of racism in one
photo
hard to beat unless there's a picture of
farrakhan and david duke dressed as the
olsen twins
which there is
she's got to look for it and now
operatives from the disgraced lincoln
project forced supporters to pretend to
be racist fans of republican challenger
glenn younkin they showed up in khakis
and white shirts you know the official
uniform of the white supremacist or 8th
grade science teachers
the hell tiki torches has a call back to
the charlottesville calamity that left a
woman dead their goal a racist smear but
remember this is the pervert led lincoln
project they should have lit those
torches and use them to keep their
co-founder away from young men
thank you
but this hoax was so lame even jessie
smollette would have said maybe you
should think this over
but the morons behind it were so proud
they tweeted about it until it all
started to fall apart like a burrito
made by a one-armed cook
shout out to sal
people recognize the democrat hoaxers in
the picture sad for them they will
probably never work again or i'll be
promoted to higher positions i mean this
is the democrat party we're talking
about if wearing blackface doesn't get
you fired what does but they literally
tried to smear decent people using a
hoax based on a hoax
the widely discredited fine people lie
capitalizing on the tragedy of others
such a stunt should render them less
employable than anyone not named hunter
i mean who will hire people like this
well since they are already dressed for
it maybe the gap
or a job at transportation where
attendance is not mandatory
now if we were cnn and those people were
republicans chris cuomo would already
have doxed them between sets of dumbbell
curls
the name fits
over at cnn he let a pair of dumbbells
reframe it about trump
are you getting crushed by people on the
right as a dirty tactic do you stand
behind what was done the question here
is it's not about some guys who showed
up at a rally it's why hasn't glenn
younkin denounced donald trump it was to
illustrate a point that younkin has not
denounced trump yeah that's the point
talk about an idiot sandwich with the
meathead in the middle
but it's good to see chris working
without a tie maybe he lent it to his
brother for the court date
and then they can use it to tie his
hands down to stop the groping
but as the hoax unraveled like one of
cat's weaves caught on a revolving door
democrat consultant lauren windsor
confessed on twitter that she worked
with the lincoln project to coordinate
the hoax she desperately claimed she was
defending democracy from right-wing
extremists none she could name of course
i mean if they're real why would they
have to make them up she didn't do much
of a job at that since her angry white
men included a black guy and a woman
i guess the diversity the diversity of
white supremacy strikes again
but i guess you can find white
supremacists if you look hard enough
david rooks with the chess news network
we're in new york city's diamond
district surrounded by white
supremacists everywhere you look there
dave david it's just a guy getting
coffee
white supremacists getting coffee an
anticipation of a long arduous night of
racism that awaits them it's literally
just people getting coffee and there are
white supremacists everywhere here's one
right now miss miss uh how long have you
been an angry white male oh are you get
away
you can see
this goes deeper than i thought we have
white
disguised as petite asian women
infiltrating the lincoln project to
impersonate more white supremacists i
haven't seen multi-level chess like this
since gayer kasparov spilled his diet
coke on deep blue back to you brag
that's good
so i think lauren just permanently
branded herself a dishonest hoaxer and a
liar her career's as dead as a shark's
eyes when he's biting into you she's
justice millet dead sarah silverman dead
her career so dead her only hope is a
gig with cnn
but many many democrats fell for it
like mr fart for brains
it makes you realize why he was such an
easy target for the chinese honey pot
which i admit sounds absolutely
delicious
[Laughter]
he has less control over his senses than
his sphincter
is that how you say it yeah thanks
no because he farts
okay
thought it would get a better laugh
but it's monday meanwhile the media
tries to blame republicans by focusing
on the lincoln project made up of sex
pests and unstable ex-republicans but
not a single person in the tiki photo is
a republican everyone's a democrat
impersonating their deranged fever dream
of what republicans look like their
imaginary villains are about as
realistic as me playing tyrus in his
life story
so why would the media lie like this
that's the dumbest question i've ever
asked aside from cat do you know who's
been drinking my rubbing alcohol
no
because if the dems didn't know about
this hoax how could they all be young
democratic party staffers in that
picture which means the hoax was a
democratic effort so trump condemned
nazis the dems dress as him this is what
desperation brings as parents see
mccullough for what he really is a glib
sanctimonious partisan elitist hack
you'd find more authenticity from a
milli vanilli cover band
so he decided to pull the white
supremacist cord but instead of running
republicans ruining republicans he
ruined some naive young democrats like
charlie manson did with his family of
young believers he let them do the dirty
work while he tried to distance himself
afterwards now it seems to me that the
lincoln project should be kicked off
twitter they used the site specifically
to spread vile hoaxes that could have
sparked racial violence maybe it's me
but isn't that slightly more incendiary
than questioning the science on masks
but will twitter do that unlikely oh
they're going to plug okay
thank you
and the winner goes to
but if we get but we get it if any right
wingers pulled this crap they'd be
banned threatened with arrest their
lives would be done it's true one party
is immune to all the rules and one party
subjected to them all except it's no
longer working i think we got these
losers on the run and when we catch them
let's put their tiki torches where the
sun don't shine and i'm not talking
about london seattle or behind tyrus
let's hurt him tonight's guess
she talks faster than a cocaine coffee
bean in a race car outnumbered co-host
emily companio
he's worked in more empty rooms than a
hotel cleaning lady
comedian joe mackey
she went from the president of now to
the president of wow
fox nation host tammy bruce
she's so libertarian she told
trick-or-treaters to stop asking for
handouts
fox news contributor cat tim
emily you claim to be a lawyer
um did they break i mean when they when
you pass off a hoax onto somebody else
is that eve is that like could they sue
them if they wanted to or is that just
art well anyone can always sue it's just
whether it would be successful and here
i think it's been chopped up to just a
really dirty campaign trick that we know
is totally insincere because according
to them isn't racism the worst thing
ever yeah do i perpetuate it like
according to them these guys it's
inexcusable to even dress up as
something remotely uh connoting racism
right for halloween for anything like
that so why is it okay for them in this
hoax and secondly you know you always
talk about how the democrats turn to
racism when they can't argue on policy
and they really dig in when they're
losing and they're in virginia the top
three most important things in the
latest poll conducted by by the way the
washington post and george mason
university uh the most important thing
to voters was education followed by the
economy and then covid and yonkin is
absolutely blasting the call-off on all
three
education by ten points exactly so
racism is not on the top three yeah
young kids leading them by far yeah you
have to resort to this and it makes it
okay by the playbook of their rules
because they are excused from all of
their rules if they're liberal you know
tammy it's like so they're pretending to
be a republican a racist republican
supporter of younkin the correlation
would be dress up as a sexual uh
harasser and say you're with the lincoln
project because this that wasn't that
their problem yeah yeah it would be it
would be and what's interesting to me is
having been on the left and i'd done
some of these uh false flag operations
which which normally would be kind of
easy to do but you have to do them well
and sometimes it just involves wearing a
t-shirt and sneaking into a place and
yelling something or you know that kind
of thing when i saw this
it was
clearly absurd it was ridiculous it was
like a cartoon right it's always it's
like jesse smollett it's like what the
left
imagines that their their you know their
fantasy of what the right is and it
becomes this cartoonish kind of thing
yeah and they're just they've gotten not
very good at it obviously
and the great thing i noticed though too
was that it was the internet that really
stopped it at first the speed with which
these individuals were identified as
democrats because that's what people
want to know is the specifics right how
do you know this is not true right
because this is this doesn't happen it's
ridiculous but so it was the energy just
just like with dan rather it was the
internet that got that fake george bush
letter
compared as being a you know a fake so
this is one of the even though we
complain about social media that's what
they couldn't stop twitter maybe would
have stopped it if they knew it was
coming uh the the legacy media would
have just kept covering it like it was
real yeah and and they never even
bothered to ask legacy media there never
went up to these people saying who are
you yeah where are you coming from it
never occurred so bravo to the internet
it's funny too because these are the
people joe that are were laughing
whenever anybody talks about false flags
and they're the ones faulting the flags
we'll be right back
would you ever agree joe
to doing a stunt like that if you knew
that it would work
no greg i'm an honest guy for the most
part so far as anyone knows
and i'll tell you what uh sometimes i'll
go to my local donut shop and i'll
purchase some donuts but then i'll
decide that i didn't buy enough donuts
so i'll throw a ball cap and some
sunglasses on and go back to the donut
shop
that way they'll never know that's why i
smelled a rat right right off the bat
here yeah
what is a lot of donuts for you like
what's an average average donut uh
pass greg back to you
i miss donuts i can't eat donuts anymore
you you can you just have to work out a
lot and i
don't so cat it's kind of amazing how
nobody's doxing these people i mean i we
couldn't find out their names but we we
don't even care we don't it's not like
we're running around trying to hunt them
down the way cnn went after people who
make memes right because also and
there's no situation where if your best
option is to lie that means that things
are going well yeah like like officer i
don't know how that crack pipe got in my
mouth like that's not a guy yeah
whose things are going well for but this
is even worse in a way because that's a
guy who's lying to defend himself they
are proactively getting out of bed being
like we're gonna do this hoax this isn't
true which i don't understand how you
get out of bed to go do something
for a cause that you know is actually
just something you made up yourself yeah
i i don't get it and to think like i am
assuming those people were fairly young
and naive but i just looked at their
they didn't seem very happy doing it no
i've been young i've been very naive
very
i've never done that yeah also it's a
hoax
if you spread a hoax on twitter that's
misinformation lincoln projects
shouldn't be on facebook i mean i'm just
strictly going by their criteria right
you know
you know
that's two rounds of applause for me
today congrats and it's um we all have
hangovers i don't i ordered burger king
on my way home and i ate it and i feel
great all right up next
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else